il va falloir vous y habituer les
Mercedes vont désormais affluer dans la
zone d'activité du pas du lac de Montini
le Bretonneux ce matin a eu lieu la pose
symbolique de la première pierre du
chantier du nouveau siège de la marque
en présence d'élus locaux le Star Center
c'est son nom en interne regroupera plus
de 700 collaborateurs du siège de
Mercedes-Benz France actuellement à
rquancour et sa filiale financière de
baahi ainsi que le centre de formation
de la cour neuve le campus s'étendra sur
20000 M carré entre les avenues Newton
NIPS et Franklin le bâtiment gris sur la
gauche abritera la Mercedes-Benz Academy
centre de formation où seront exposés
aux collaborateurs les nouveaux modèles
de camions Vanes et voitures sur la
droite l'immeuble du siège social
mesurera environ 34 m de haut des stores
extérieurs habilleront les grandes
baaies vitrées un concept novateur en
France autour 500 arbres seront plantés
et une rivière sèche pour gérer l'eau de
pluie aujourd'hui un parking souterrain
de plus de 400 places est déjà terminé
des exigences du client le la rampe de
parking a été dimensionnée pour que de
maybar puissent se croiser pour qu'une
eslr ne frotte pas quand elle quand elle
franchira la rampe voilà c'est les
petits détails auquels un promoteur au
quotidien n'est pas habitué et ça
faisait plaisir d'avoir un utilisateur
qui était soucieux du détail de la
qualité de la construction ce nouvel
écrin de construction écologique
labelllisé correspond aux ambition de la
marque allemande dans ce contexte
économique tendu Mercedes TI sa position
de manière tout à fait encourageante en
2012 plus 9 % d'immatriculation de
voiture une croissance de nos camions
dans un marché en recul et finalement le
maintien de notre rôle d'acteur majeur
pour les utilitaires Mercedes Benz c'est
sur une bonne voie et avec notre vaste
offensif de produits notre objectif
reste d'lagir encore plus no de marché
opération séduction réussie pour Montin
le Bretonneux 2013 belle et bien l'année
des chantiers entre l'arrivée du
Vélodrome la construction de la gare
routière urbaine et de l'estaka école
d'ingénieur en automobile à l'heure où
des villes perdent des entreprises nous
nous en gagnons ce qui est quand même le
le signe de la grande attractivité de
notre agglomération et de la ville de
montinil broteneux la deuxième chose
aussi c'est le signe du renouveau de la
zone d'activité du pas du lac livraison
prévu en janvier 2014 comme exigé par la
marque à
l'étoile